[Music]
when I am stage I think that the world
is mine and I am prepared because I am
dancing
I believe the state that I can find I am
David and surely I am pesos officially
georgian national party georgian
national dance is a folk dance comprised
of strong athletic movements from the
male dancers and floating effortless
movement from the female the unique
choreography combines folk with
classical ballet and modern dance and
the company's best are part of Georgia's
original professional dance company
shoka's Billie our dance company exists
more than 70 years and the my
grandparents created this best company
it was holding you to that that the
georgian dance became so popular in my
country now why would this company with
more than 100 dancers and their lives
been the company has traveled around the
world and sent its creation has
performed in front of over 15 million
people the preparing take the stage six
years of rigorous practice they need a
lot of training because we perform very
difficult dances and complicated
movements we dance on because and they
have nothing inside like a thin leather
boot I have injuries here everywhere but
now I am in good form every day we are
painting from the morning doing ballet
classes then we are swimming and when we
arrive as possible
we use sabers and sold you the dances
and they need to have some good psychic
skills to be a show cat belly dancer is
a huge honor in Georgia and with the
school of over 3,000 dancers and
training the future of traditional
Georgian folk dance is great I hope the
bad georgian bands will be popular
always because it's very maturity we do
our job as a great loss we dedicated our
lives to this
[Music]